overall the number of ultra
high-net-worth individuals so 90% of our
order but will come from alter ultra
high-net-worth individuals we expect
that to grow by about 20 percent between
now and 2020 so we're in a good position
there we've also found a real niche in
credibility in bridging the 50 feet up
to 150 feet that get moving into the
super yacht category we've we celebrated
in 2015 the hundredth delivery of boats
over a hundred feet long so we're very
very credible there and that's where the
real the real growth is so between
between 50 and 150 feet we're the number
one manufacturer in the world that's
fascinating we're hitting a sweet spot I
look at Russia under pressure
I look at Petro dollars turned to petrol
pennies and I look at China which the
whole world is absorbed by what are you
seeing from your customers who are the
customers we've seen tremendous growth
at the moment in Asia and North America
a lot of recovery North America some
stability in Europe as you brightly
point out there are areas of the world
that have got instability but Sunseeker
as a brand is represented in all the
major markets around the world and
overall we're seeing some strong growth
now its bonus season around the world
and you've got a plethora of different
boats to offer everybody from London New
York Hong Kong and Paris the Sunseeker
range what can I get for I know a
million bucks five million bucks and ten
we have quite a range of products we are
we start around about half a million
pounds up to 25 million pounds it's not
an impulsive purchase though we work
with our customers for a long period of
time in terms of specifying their boats
a lot is bespoke so they will come to
pool I come to the UK on a number of
occasions as are actually going through
the build process it's not a short field
post it's a very detailed emotional
purchase we work very very closely with
owners with their families and actually
specify something that's very very
unique to them and very very that's the
catch which it which is bespoke it is
the critical draw and it's my boat it's
my creation it's part of my personality
when you get to super yachts yes thus
bespoke elements of that in terms of
feature in terms of materials to an
extent design it's all about their
personal requirements what are they
going to be using the boat for but we do
sell a huge range of products not just
super yachts we start at at 48 feet
right up to 155 feet so our consumers
are are different but one thing that is
consistent it's it's an emotional
purchase it's a discretionary purchase
people don't need yachts they want
yachts they desire it's what they can
actually do with them talking about the
shift in luxury you come front from a
heavy background of luxury brands give
me your sense of the shift in transit
there's more and more customers that are
desiring well-known luxury brands and
they are becoming more accessible the
world is despite the global recession we
had the world is becoming a more after
place as more and more affluent people
that desire these brands but something
that we are definitely seeing is an
increase in the number of discerning
customers people that buy in luxury
brands they're successful but that's why
they're able to buy them and they demand
excellent customer service